speaking of the steelers who once
employed antonio brown at the beginning
this year they had him up until the
middle of march they had him and then he
was traded to the raiders and then he
ended up with the patriots and now he's
awaiting
the outcome of the nfl's investigation
regarding his potential personal conduct
policy violation there was development
in one of his umpteen pending pieces of
litigation that i think is very
important to what's coming for him as it
relates to the nfl
there was a report yesterday that a
lawsuit filed against him by a former
miami landlord for damages done to the
apartment and this is related to the
throwing the furniture off the balcony
incident inside the apartment damage was
done they've sued him for that he showed
up for deposition testimony last month
which is a pre-trial process where you
get an opportunity
to question under oath the parties to a
lawsuit to find out what they know to
test out some theories to see how they
are as witnesses and you just basically
have a booklet that comes out of it that
you can use when it's time to go to
trial you already have testimony you
already have answers to the questions
and they better stick with those answers
later that's the purpose of the
deposition
well antonio brown according to the
landlord was belligerent was hostile was
not cooperative and they wanted to be
sanctioned by the court and they wanted
to have to give another deposition now
that'll all play out in court and the
deposition is what it is the transcript
says what it says the video doesn't lie
and i'm not surprised to learn that
antonio brown was potentially hostile
and belligerent when he was forced to
answer a bunch of tough questions how
this is relevant
to
antonio brown and the nfl investigation
is very simple
at some point he's going to be asked
tough questions by the nfl at some point
they're going to sit him down and he's
going to have that smile but behind that
smile is going to be that fire that we
know is there and at some point
somebody's going to say something to him
that he doesn't like and he's going to
be uncooperative and the problem is if
you're a bad witness even if you're
telling the truth if you are a bad
communicator of that truth if you come
across as a bad person if you come
across as an angry person they're going
to be less likely to believe you and
there are plenty of great liars under
oath and there are plenty of horrible
truth tellers and antonio brown may be
completely blameless but if he's a bad
witness when it's time for the nfl to
interview him it increases the chances
that they're going to believe his
accuser and if they ultimately
conclude that antonio brown committed
rape even though he was never arrested
and charged criminally if they believe
he did it
i think he's banned for life i don't
think you can say as the nfl we think
antonio brown committed rape but you
know we're uh
we're just gonna suspend him six games
so the stakes are going to be very high
for antonio brown when it's time for him
to be questioned by the nfl based on how
he allegedly performed in this lawsuit
involving his apartment
it's not going to go well for antonio
brown when it's time to talk to the
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports